senior insider for NBC Sports Bay Area
joining us ray Matt may I ask you about
draymond Green are you're gonna give me
the Durant answer you can ask me
whatever you like this is your show
that's why your names on it
so what do you make of all of this ray I
mean how concerned should a warrior fan
be with all this because is this the is
this the real deal is this the real the
real inside implosion that tears
dynasties asunder the other done these
are the sons yes it it depends on how
you want to define dynasty because this
is really not about this season it's
about the off season you know Durant's
not going anywhere until June Green's
not going anywhere until June I think
they are both smart enough to know that
nobody nobody benefits from them turning
this into a poop show it's you know go
out win another ring and then you can do
whatever you want so I mean basically
the the narrative has been all along
let's fast-forward through this tedious
basketball and get to the real fun of
finding out whether Durant wants to be a
Nick or a Laker I mean it's it's almost
like basketball has become sort of a
byproduct of the real show which is
finding out where players are going to
go get their next 40 million-dollar
cotton and in the meantime basketball
games get in the way so what you're
saying well it's yeah well I mean it
does now because everybody and I mean
everybody has already seated the
championship to Golden State barring a
catastrophic injury or set of injuries
so I mean all this has been about all
year long has been where's the rant
going next year what's Durant thinking
about next year it's it's like they
can't wait to be done with the 2018-19
season and it's a it's 20 games in you
know not even it's you know it's we
already know what's going to happen next
now we want to know what happens after
next I mean it's
triumph of our cultural lack of patience
more than anything else don't tell us
what's about to happen you know give us
9 alternate universes for next season
and then the season after that I mean
it's I find it I find it bizarre I find
it hilarious well I'm part of it ring I
I awarded I awarded the Larry French I
ordered the Larry Francis O'Brien trophy
to them on what date was it again Chris
Brown October 30 yeah so it's coming up
on almost a month that I did that my
question relate I I was but at some
point though I guess everybody's gonna
have to realize that in order for the
next contracts before it happens it
would be better to have on your legacy
sheet another championship so what where
does do you think Steve Kerr's role in
all this is because he's the coach he
needs to he's the one that realizes that
games need to be won before any free
agency hits what do you think here right
well I think everybody there realizes
that and that you know when draymond
Green said this was a bump in the road
to a certain extent it was but the
Warriors are you know they're they're
every bit as guilty of looking past this
season as anybody because next year they
go into a new building and it's a new
building across the bay they've got a
you know basically take their fan base
and then add to it because a lot of
people are going to drop off because
they're not going to go across the bay
and deal with the nightmares of traffic
and and higher prices and all that they
have to rebuild a fan base they have to
you know make keep this machine going
and if they go into a new building and
all of a sudden the Warriors are not as
advertised like they were the previous
four or five years then all of a sudden
now you know the blooms off the rows and
I think you know everybody including the
organization has been caught looking
down the road you know we've got to keep
this going because of next year we've
got to keep this going because
we're trying to you know we're trying to
build our legacy it's now everybody the
entire National Basketball Association
all 30 of its constituent teams and
every fan is looking ahead to 2020 it's
when you look back at this in five years
you will realize how insane this all is
and that we are all part of it
and Steve cars caught in the middle of
it because he is in many ways an
old-school guy you know I mean I he you
know he's a he's a modern coach he lets
players you know he players but you know
he you know he was a guy who with grit
his teeth and take the charge and you
know get into the fight with Michael
Jordan because that's what you do you
know and now he's dealing with a dynamic
and Bob Meyers is dealing with a dynamic
and Joel a cop's dealing with a dynamic
in which the immediacy of coaching and
playing is almost secondary to our
fascination with down the road and in no
other sport is that happening right now
it's not happening in the NFL I mean the
NFL is classic right now I mean the Los
Angeles Rams are built for the right now
the wari the Warriors back story is what
comes after this because we've already
decided that this isn't entertaining
enough we want we want next and that's
where they're all that that's where
we're all that it's tough to argue that
that in the crucible of a game like
Monday Rey game on the line draymond
dribbles it out and Kevin Durant calls
him out for it and you may say that he
might have been a bit too demonstrative
certainly for somebody as potentially
sensitive as draymond Green and greens
first thought is to go down the road
about that decision in the middle of
just the heat of the battle in early
November it really is kind of coming
from a certain spot that you wouldn't
normally expect it to come from
well I mean it's look that the Durant
warriors dynamic is an interesting one
it's probably the most interesting thing
about them right now because on the one
hand you've got a number of warriors who
you know want to say but haven't what
more do you want you know what is it
we're not providing you you know and
talking to Kevin Durant what is it we're
not providing for you that doesn't make
you say it's a no-brainer for me to come
back and Durant is saying without saying
it I want to see what else is out there
I'm curious about what it would be like
if I you know listen to the Knicks or if
I listen to the Lakers or I listen to
the Phoenix Suns whatever and draymond
Green is the guy who says the unpleasant
truth unfiltered at a loud volume and he
chose the wrong time to do it he chose
the wrong venue to do it and he chose
the wrong way to do it but this has been
kind of a quiet undercurrent that sort
of flies in the face of the Warriors
fascination with letting everybody know
how everybody gets along so very well
every day because they're all United and
being in the pursuit of victory well
there's more than victory again this is
you know this is about what's coming
after this I mean they've reached the
point where they assume a championship
because everybody does and now they're
looking for well what's the next fun
narrative to chase down Durant's
whereabouts or the next narrative I
guess in the short term is well the
whereabouts and readiness of Steph Curry
would be of interest certainly since
you'd think that it wouldn't have been
draymond Green dribbling the ball out to
start this whole thing off this week if
khari was healthy and more wins is
exactly the deodorant that's required
for this sort of thing what can you tell
us about that any idea when he comes
back ma I'm it looks like it's going to
be at least another ten days to two
weeks
he's not playing on this road trip
they haven't even said they're you know
they haven't even given a date for when
they're going to reevaluate him so I
think this might be a while but I think
one of the things that's that's going to
happen is that curry is going to be more
sort of present around the team even
though you know he doesn't have to be
because part of why this all blew up I
think a lot of people believe is because
curry wasn't there on the Monday night
and curry is the one thing around which
everybody can unite because all the
players not only respect him but love
him for the way he has not acted like
your standard IVA / superstar and they
all recognize that he was the guy who
was at Golden State before everybody
else so he's got cachet that nobody else
has and it it has not been lost on
people that the one night he stayed home
is when this blew up now I don't know
what he could have done to prevent it
because when draymond Green wants to say
something he's going to say it but you
know there there's there's there's
always a backstory that the one thing
that keeps this all sort of together
more than anything else of all the
things that find them the thing that
binds the most is curry and it's not
that they worship Him but they recognize
that he's earned that in a way that
nobody else the franchise has I mean not
current up Myers not dream not Thompson
that curry is the core of this all
mm-hmm and I think they you know if if
in fact nerds are still afraid and
there's no real way of knowing because
they they all seem to play nice last
night except one actually had to play
that Curry's presence is the one calming
influence that that they all agree on
and it's not because they they worship
Him it's the
because he's earned it and the NBA is
incredibly hierarchical that way it's
you know in there are pecking orders for
players and couriers at the apex so that
when he's around things are calm because
he's the one guy who doesn't insist on
his place they give it to him because he
doesn't insist on so I think he's not
gonna play for a while but I think he's
going to be very very present yeah and
he also exudes joy which can be
contagious and it's obviously something
that's lacking right now and that
Warriors team one last thing for you ray
I don't mean to I guess I'm not
correcting I'm just adding perspective
to what you said about how the NBA is
the only spot where the people are
looking down the road as opposed to
right now and just for in terms of
championship teams because in the NFL
the Raiders are absolutely they can be
on the road I mean this is a tank job
we're seeing right now right right well
the players aren't tanking that's
correct
neither electric neither the coaches but
the organization is tunneling towards
the Earth's core and part of the reason
why this went so bad so quickly is
because Jon Gruden the general manager
you know is every bit as impatient as
Jon Gruden a coach and he couldn't wait
once he decided this needed to be torn
down and rebuilt he couldn't wait to
start and the players glommed onto that
pretty quickly and they said okay none
of us are gonna be here in a year you
know what we'll give you will give you
the 95 percent that you have to give
keep from getting hurt on any given
Sunday but you're not getting it the
last five I think that he's lost sort of
the daily connection with them and they
with him not in a way where they're
being insubordinate but there's there's
just nothing that that sort of connects
that team except that man I can't wait
for this to hear and it's not quitting
it's just sort of you know not seeing
not seeing anything at the end of this
row except unemployment and that
pretty dispiriting in a sport that asks
so much of your body and I think that's
that's the biggest problem here it said
nobody's quits but they could see they
could see the value in quitting you know
nobody's given up but they can see the
value in the end of the season and it's
hard to keep keep the parade going when
there's no music right love the chats as
always thanks again have a great
Thanksgiving know you have a great thing
you bet that's ray r @o @ r @o n BCS so
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience